you already know rogue ricks used mortys
to hide themselves from the citadel
but you might not know it worked so well
that the citadel became its own morty
martin
and he's attached to us infinitely
through his weakness
and our forgiveness this music oh the
killing floor it's like the matrix
oh my god
oh this is i i don't i feel very weird
welcome back to new rock stars the rick
and morty season five finale answers all
our big questions about evil morty's
long game plan rick's true backstory and
the dark truth behind the nature of rick
and morty's relationship leaving online
theorists nothing left to talk about
really what the what the
come on chef loveness you're an amazing
rider but you don't have to clip all the
branches of possibility for us he's like
i'm leaving this is my last stop he's
like i'm out burning it all down
man he crushed it this is an incredible
finale i just i loved everything that
was here this is rick splained by the
way this is our rick and morty after
show where we're gonna condense
everything we just learned for you
dum-dums i'm just kidding we had to
re-watch a few seeds ourselves because
uh did we get any of that no we're gonna
speculate on where this could possibly
go next i'm eric boss my easter egg
breakdown of all the details you missed
in this two-part finale is coming
tomorrow but here i am reacting to this
finale with tommy bechtel hey
oh my god i uh i don't feel so good
is it because you've lost your beard
that beard was your layer of protection
and that beard was my power that beard
would have absorbed all of the truth
that we took in from these episodes and
now it's that i'm left here barefaced
and bare sold
yeah take in what we've learned
so we're going to explain what this
central finite curve really is and how
this episode recontextualized the
initial citadel of rick's episode in
season one as well as the return of evil
morty in season three and we're going to
look at whether this series will now
follow evil morty through the yellow
portals and really what that portal will
lead to uh before we get to that one of
the best ways you can support us here at
new rockstars is to check out our merch
at newrockstarsmerch.com we got some
awesome brand new designs for shanghi as
well as merch inspired by what if like
what i'm wearing suicide squad spiderman
no way home and more oh yeah tommy i see
you got your king shark shirt i love
that shirt
so you can get all this stuff at
newrockstarsmerch.com uh so right now
tommy and i are gonna basically do an
explanation of the ending and he and i
are gonna tag team it because there's
just been there's so much implication
that came from this so uh after rick
tries to replace morty with two crows
and uh kind of becomes samurai jack
figure morning tries to lure him back
with an aging serum uh so they need to
go back to the citadel to fix it i
believe this is uh rick's first time
back to the citadel because in season
three episode seven he and morty didn't
actually go there they were at the rick
lantis mix-up probably hanging out with
mr nimbus but there was a whole other
world that was happening with the
citadel of rix where evil morty took it
over so this is rick's first time
setting foot back in there and now evil
morty's plan can be set into motion
because yes we see evil morty we know
this is the same one back from that
season one episode nine episode as the
stan lee rick told us to re-watch this
episode
oh so good amazing oh my god and just to
clear up any confusion season one
episode nine is the close rick counters
episode when you don't count the pilot
episode so i know that the numbering
system might be a little weird there um
and yes that was the same order who
charmed his way into being the president
of the citadel and we now learned that
his goal was to steal rick c137's
knowledge of the central finite curve so
essentially since morty's help ricks
stay hidden from each other they have
the inverse brain waves that cancel each
other out uh rather than waiting for
naturally born mortys to occur across
the multiverse ricks created the system
where they began interfering with events
to force alternate reality beths and
cherries to fall in love in cases where
they might not have fell in love and
then they began straight up cloning
those mortys farming them matrix style
to pair them with random ricks to meet
the demand and these realities were
assembled in a curve of toxic pairings
between these slave mortys and ricks
from realities where they were the
smartest person in that reality so evil
morty's plan is to destroy that curve
kill all the ricks and mortys in the
citadel and escape to a new reality
where rick's backstory never came to be
but tommy we also learned what that
backstory was we got some firm answers
on it so what was that backstory the
backstory from season three episode one
was confirmed finally rick as a young
scientist was visited by random [ __ ]
rick whom he turned down and that rick
killed both beth and diane with a bomb
which rick addresses in this episode
very carelessly rick guy invented his
own portal gun to find the killer he
scoured the multiverse succeeded at
hunting dozens of alternative ricks who
were loosely associated in the rick gang
but never found his target and thus he
became the toxic [ __ ] we've come to
know
i want to say love but i think it's just
because it's a cartoon that we know is
not real if he was a real person we'd be
terrified uh he befriends bird person
who turned on him at the battle of blood
ridge
as we saw a few episodes ago and as
other ricks try to murder him he kills
them all but he eventually forms a truce
with them to build the citadel which
then he helped him assemble the central
finite curve tommy you bring up a good
point that if rick existed in real life
he'd be terrifying which i think we all
saw from the christopher lloyd shorts
that happened over the weekend like
these promos like
it's so funny because rick is based on
doc from bart from back to the future so
for christopher lloyd to come back and
just commit so hard to this that would
be terrifying if we knew that guy yeah
absolutely so evil morty explains this
episode that the central finite curve is
a wall between all universes in the
multiverse and the universes in which
rick is the smartest person alive so
until now every green portal that we've
seen in the show has only led to a
universe where rick was the smartest
person in that universe that's kind of
been rick's secret hack this whole
series but evil morty's plans to erase
that curve and escape all of that into a
new universe where rick isn't a genius
inventor that he is and that's why eva
morty's portal glows yellow now so we
needed rick c137's memory because c137
rick saw that full curve being assembled
and only c137 knows the full distinction
between his network and universes where
he's not the alpha genius technically
evil morty could have done all of this
just by scanning and killing literally
every other rick and just applying the
process of elimination but this way is
faster but one of my favorite details
from this episode is that is what evil
morty was doing all this time for all he
knew seba 37 rick was never gonna come
back to the citadel so his plan was to
just go rick by rick and scan this
information and just eliminate them
that's why we saw like very few ricks
comparatively walking around the
background citadel this time because
evil morty was working his way down the
line just assembling this curve pod by
pod uh just one step at a time and he's
like oh c137 is back great okay we can
jump right to the end step of my plan i
think that is so devious insidious and
amazing so evil morty uses the citadel's
minds of portal fluid to create a rift
in reality that's separate from the
central finite curve and he hacked every
rick's portal gun so that they would be
killed if they ever tried to leave
during this moment and in order to
ensure a clean slate he also stayed a
step ahead of their operation phoenix
plant so that any rick and morty who
tried to respawn would be immediately
grounded up and then he seemed like he
used their blood to erase those central
finite curve realities that they
specifically were linked to as a way to
kind of like undo it so he he used that
as a contingency it is brilliant to
think about everything that he did i
know it's brilliant but it's just so
crazy
so
we can assume from this that if rick
c137 is the rickiest rick
the rickest rick is the rickest rick and
morty we've been following is the
morniest morty yeah because he was a
naturally occurring morty one in the
wild beautiful to see them out of
captivity uh the one that several other
mortys have been in fact cloned from
yeah it all happened so fast but like
that morty was born naturally there
might have been other naturally
occurring mortys right we saw different
meat cutes between beth and jerry but
like that was one where morty was
sleeping it was implied that rick got
the blood from in order to just make
this farm so this morty is not a clone
who knows how many naturally occurring
mortys there are left i assume evil
morty is one of those to have been
around for so long i i just assume there
is something more particular and special
but that's a good point that this does
make our morty probably in the running
for the mortyus morty but to be clear i
think it's an important distinction when
rick c137 began his journey there was no
citadel yet there was no central finite
curve yet there was only just that loose
gang of ricks and you know they were
part of that gang they had that r symbol
which it's interesting to think about
our rake later co-opted when he built
the citadel that was the original
citadel logo he stole it from this kind
of ragtag gang of ricks who were you
know doing they were hanging out in a
bar they had like a clubhouse you know
and they had like the connection of
ricks that were connected via yarn that
was what that one rick was building to
try to connect with them but that rick
was never found and so rick just kind of
stood on his shoulders to build like a
network of ricks but we never really
know what happened to that we'll talk
about that later um but uh it was our
rick who built the citadel who launched
the
morty farming scheme to assemble the
central finite curve that i think we
could say eventually led to evil morty's
rise because those are the conditions
that created evil morty and turned him
into the
bastard that he is so i think the
question we should now ask tommy is what
did happen to that [ __ ] rick who
killed diane and beth because he was
never found was that guy just you know
something that they'll never address
some inevitable product of an expanding
rick multiverse
um is this some other villain that we're
now gonna be chasing on the series or
could he actually be some nobody and
that bomb i'm gonna reach here could
that bomb have been dropped by evil
morty in order to send rick down this
long long road to eventually crack the
code of living in a multiverse base not
on ricks but now we have a multiverse
based on evil morty he is the alpha
genius of the series now he now seems
like the nexus being we might now have
yellow portals on this show what do you
think tommy i don't know that's crazy to
think about i uh
i mean i guess it's it's all one of
those things of like
it just depends on where the show's
going from here but i i i do hope
i love the idea that it was evil morty
that just sent a random that would be so
rick and morty right to just have it not
be a special wreck like it was just like
a random rake that was sent by another
thing
just undercut your expectations every
way ah
but i also would be curious if this was
some sort of like
enlightened hyper-enlightened rick
that like figured out that like
ricks were inevitably going to lead to
the demise of the universe or ricks were
only going to lead to suffering so he
just you know went around and and killed
and whatever and ruined their lives but
uh yeah i've just seen that bomb was
meant for rick not for yeah of course
yes that was i think my assumption from
season three episode one that he was
just like which is so funny because and
not funny funny funny so so i guess uh
interesting because in the movie tropes
and tv tropes we have when a bomb
accidentally kills the wrong target that
usually leads the person who was the
target to go on a righteous path of
revenge but rick's path of revenge is
always self-serving it's not like he's
actually mourning the loss of those two
people really right
he just wants to figure out how someone
got one over on him yes i think that i
think you're exactly right uh i i mean i
think ultimately there's there's like
three general paths ahead of us of
what comes next from rick's journey when
it comes to him trying to get over diane
actually four one is that it never comes
up again because i think the writers
were just like good now we never have to
talk about it again you know uh so
that's one possibility second
possibility is that uh that rick that
reiku killed him is going to be kind of
a white rabbit for our rape yeah you
know and that maybe he is kind it does
present like a dastardly alternate rick
who did have his own version of the
citadel somewhere in the multiverse that
eva morty didn't know about because we
did see him in the early stages of
trying to connect everyone you know with
that yarn grab him it seemed like that
rick was uh it was almost like a
highlander thing like he was so genius
you know it was like his one guy that he
could never find he might still be out
there and he might have had his own
alternate citadel that is crazier or
just like you know more specific or
creative contingencies to prevent the
rise of an evil morty who knows uh
third option is that it could have been
evil morty i think that is a reach
option though because it just seems like
a lot of extra steps for eva morty to
create all this suffering for himself
and all of his alternate mortys
just to i feel like there would be an
easier way for him to take over that
didn't require or the fourth one is kind
of like we're gonna find at some point
that one of the ricks that rick killed
or has seen over the years was that
alternate rick
and or maybe even someone like doofus
rick or something like that yeah and our
rick has met that guy and
just has never bothered to scan him to
see you know and that's kind of like the
most uh
nihilistic answer i think that like rick
has now given up his search for the
person who killed his wife and daughter
originally
and he's run into like infinite numbers
of ricks and he just never really
thought to
to check to see if this could be the guy
and that we might have already met this
killer and it just doesn't matter
anymore well that'd be a very rick and
morty way
to handle it
yeah um so we there's so much more from
this episode we want to discuss real
quick just to thank some people who
sponsored us this show was sponsored by
better help so is something interfering
with your happiness and preventing you
from achieving your goals we've all been
there at some point betterhelp will
assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional therapist
start communicating in under 48 hours
better help is not a crisis line or
self-help it is professional counseling
done securely online there is a broad
range of expertise available for clients
worldwide just log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
counselor you won't ever have to sit in
an uncomfortable waiting room or look
for parking better help makes it easy
and free to change counselors if you
need to it's more affordable the
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available better help
wants you to start living a happier life
today so visit betterhelp.com
ricksplained that's better h-e-l-p and
join the over 1 million people who have
taken charge of their mental health with
the help of an experienced professional
in fact so many people have been using
betterhelp that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
special offer for explained audience get
10 percent off your first month at
betterhelp.com explained we also want to
thank helix sleep for sponsoring this
episode you don't want to sleep on a
mattress design for someone else even if
that other person is the darkest
timeline version of yourself they
probably like a super firm mattress and
always sleep on the side of their body
without the eye patch helix sleep has a
quiz that matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you they have soft medium
and firm mattresses mattress is great
for cooling you down if you sleep hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers i have a helix mattress and i
love it the quiz matched me with a
medium firm mattress with lumbar support
that sleeps cool that's right i'm
sleeping like i'm living cool
yeah
the mattress shifts right to your door
for free no need to go to a mattress
store just go to
helixsleep.com take their two minutes
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life helix is
offering up to 200 off mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
at helix sleep.com ricksplained all
right so back to the episode tommy i i'm
curious to know your thoughts who do you
think is the star of the show now we
have marooned rick and morty on the
mortyberg section of the citadel that's
now kind of like a life raft in a weird
way but and they showed how he has no
portal fluid left
or are we going to be following evil
morty exploring his own omniverse where
he can be king of it and rick in any of
these universe is not the evil genius
but is more of just like an average
dummy i love this uh
i think
i hope
we get a few episodes of evil morty
and exploring this new world
and
we get to see characters that we love in
different iterations you know like
different multiverse versions of them
then i hope that we get a like rohan
will answer like reven like here comes
like the the cavalry of the uh of our
rick and morty from the previous five
seasons coming in around episode three
or four to defeat evil morty and restore
things which is all which is awful the
things they'd be restoring are not the
you know like they're restoring like
basically farming mortys
yeah
right right it seems like they allow
maybe one episode per season
of canonicity right yeah so yeah uh or
maybe they'll do it right at the
beginning of the season and then
somewhere towards the end of the season
they'll do something and i'm wondering
if like season six will begin with uh
following it'll the show will now be
called morty and rick yeah and then so
morty evil morty will be taking the role
of this like uh this alpha genius and
then rick will be kind of like a more
timid dummy uh but like heart of gold
version of himself
uh and then something will switch to
where we'll go back to the to the norm
of the show because i predict that
yeah it's with the amount of the
episodes they have to work on there's no
way each episode's going to completely
change the rules locally style
um
but i do wonder if like we will check
back in with this more evolved
empathetic uh rick and morty because i
think the crows part of this finale did
show that like rick did change this was
and i would argue i don't buy the
argument that rick and morty never
change i think every episode they do
change they are on an arc towards more
empathy and and guilt and shame and yeah
wanting to do what's right by each other
uh and by themselves it was so weird
what a weird yeah i know it's like this
has to be a lady this is a crow scare
the scarecrow
i love that uh and there's i know we've
skipped over a lot this is just kind of
our explanation after some of the big
takeaways from it all but you know the
garbage goober and like there's all
these little things the harvard grant
reading the new england journal of
medicine oh so beautiful um so
yeah and and let's not forget mr poopy
butthole's like tag at the end oh my god
i i i just stand up and take deep
breaths after that i really did like i
had to think like oh my god i have to i
i have to spend this labor day at least
a little bit with my fiance like i can't
get sucked into work like that it's i
felt like a message to me like step away
from work it's probably really like a uh
a test depending on if you saw that uh
however you absorbed that that code to
that episode is like what what your real
needs are like i saw it and i was like i
gotta connect with my family a little
more yeah
well i um i i think ultimately the show
is not we keep thinking that every
season where we have like the big evil
morty episode we think the whole show's
different and then like we have a couple
episodes where it's just like the fun
you know
rick and morty uh simple sci-fi idea
blowing up blowing up blown up and then
absolutely there are moments of
catharsis and empathy by the characters
because i think that is there every
episode and then we can look forward to
something at the end of the season and i
do think alpha evil morty is going to
exist at some point we're going to see
what happens to him and i think really
so the the
if you think about this writer's room
they're going by that uh story circle
right i think they have a story circle
of evil morty throughout the seas series
right
and they asked what they got green light
for 70 episodes a couple years ago i
think they have an end game in mind for
where he's going and i think he is at
the um
the find part of the circle the six
o'clock region where he gets what he
wanted you know right but not
necessarily what he needs
right so i think we're gonna see the
second half though the harder part of
his journey where he has to pay a price
for getting what he thought he wanted
and then we're going to see his change
over the result so i'm very excited to
see the second half of his curve tommy i
want to ask you uh assuming rick
eventually settled on a reality where
beth survived that was part of his
backstory
in those particular realities what
happened to the dianes did the bomb only
hit diane did she die from something
else
i think that's still an unanswered
question well you know not to cross over
brands here but uh if they do a little
what if
uh perhaps diane is destined to die no
matter what even if he uh
maybe beth was hard maybe it would be a
very rick and morty thing if beth was an
insignificant death in that moment on
the timeline and diane was the
significant death so even if he can go
to a place where beth survived diane
always dies another way because that's
what it
she's the takes point that christine
palmer to the doctor strange you know
like she she has to die and that's what
makes rick rick i know it probably won't
be that but i i think that
given
the way rick sanchez's character is
she's dead no matter what i don't think
she's ever coming back i don't think i
don't think there's ever going to be a
real
version of
like a real episode where he's dealing
with the real diane someone evil might
figure out a way to have cloned diane to
trick him i think that that's gonna be
the the show
relies on so much actual emotion
hidden behind cartoon characters and
aliens and mutated beings i think that
the death of a spouse is one thing that
they might actually consider
sacred sounds like the wrong word i
think she's dead long story short i
think she's dead in all you i think
you're right tommy uh and if she is not
dead i think it's not happy for rick i
think like that visit from that [ __ ]
rick was just like the tip of the
iceberg it was the taste it was the
first hit for rick to meet another nars
you know to
awaken his inner narcissism that i think
he was born with so i think even if she
survived
uh she would have left him and i think
that's
one thing that is left to discover about
rick's backstory is that no matter what
it never ends with him and diane happy
together absolutely i want to ask i
think this might be obvious but do you
think rick's affinity for crows is
connected to his bird person enduring
love
i mean short answer yes probably i also
think that he just loved the crows
because they listened to him without and
they couldn't they couldn't talk back
they couldn't question anything he did
and in the end they proved to be
supremely loyal to him even after they
evolved into
sentient speaking crows they still
they still did the the the string trick
with him
being the perfect partners for him
from the promise of uh crow quaaludes
right
yeah right right you got it guys
i love that they turn right before they
did it they turned and said oh so
perfect that that might have been the
hardest laugh for me of that episode for
sure yeah i i just see some bird person
connection to this because remember back
in that uh bird person eternal sunshine
episode there uh he kept some of phoenix
person's wings
like that was just he put that in a
separate pile and then it shows back up
in this episode the shield that he uses
is tech that he harvested from phoenix
person i love that they brought that
back it might have been one of my
favorite details in the first half of
the episode and uh so i think this is
largely i know it was randomized on the
wheel right right i think the fact that
he stuck with it and i think there was
like a bit of joy the fact that it
landed on the crows the fact that pros
were an option at all i think it was he
goes to this avian planet i think that
is connected to his love of bird person
how i'll never let bird person go well
tommy do you think final question is
jerry still a puddle the most important
question of all
i hope so because when you talk about
final forms
puddle jerry is perfect for jerry he can
be stepped on
he's an inconvenience
there's like multiple satisfying ways to
get rid of him he's mopey like a puddle
he's a party he's a wet blanket he can
literally become a wet blanket now i
think puddle jerry is the final form of
my one of my favorite characters in any
cartoon yeah me too
me too uh i like i i know
the show isn't so strictly canon that
will probably see jerry revert to human
form but if we can just get to see what
happened next from uh puddle jerry uh
yeah or if like we just revisit him a
few times with him just being a puddle
the way that we followed rick as pickle
rick for a whole episode
the puddle jerry episode i could imagine
there being a comment in like episode
two of season six where they're at the
table and everybody like there's a real
crisis
and then jerry brings up well i was a
puddle for six months or something like
that and everyone just goes like not now
jerry or something like that that'll be
the
yeah i want to see like uh jerry get
evaporated and it just becomes like a a
lesson magic school bus style on the
water cycle yeah
he gets dumped this acid rain you notice
we saw the brain in the planet
never mind that's what i want and like
yeah and we just see like this is what's
happening with our climate water gets
evaporated and it doesn't always return
back as precipitation you know no uh
yeah anyway well uh that completes this
season of rick splayed again my easter
egg uh breakdown of the final two
episodes it is coming tomorrow it's
labor day for us right now but for some
reason i stupidly chose to work today so
just go easy on me don't tweet them and
i gladly chose to work today
but i know a lot of you uh only seem to
care about the easter eggs and the
animation details i just know that from
our view numbers but for those of you
true believers who have joined tommy and
me for this season on ricksplained to
react and to theorize and to joke around
about these episodes honestly that's
been the more fun part about this
process for me tommy just being able to
join you for all of this that's what i
look forward to every week uh being able
to spend monday mornings with you i i
pray to god the boys underground comes
back and we can do that
uh hopefully soon and uh and tommy it's
just great to be able to join you on
your roster something that isn't doing
weird fitness challenge yes absolutely
enjoy the life i enjoy the lack of
planks on this show
it's a bit easier for sure uh so be sure
to follow tommy at tommy bechtold follow
me at eavos follow new rockstar
subscribe to ricksplained wherever you
get your podcasts thank you for watching
and we'll close with our favorite moment
from the episode mmm trash i love trash
yum yum trash i wanna eat trash
[Music]
you
[Music]